[Musique]
massot de temps afin si je te ferai
passer le polygraphe trek sa wind mis en
orbite tout d'abord bonne fight
[Rires]
merci c'est aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on
soit comme cadeau de fête un comédien
qui à 38 ans de carrière
ça fait plusieurs années que je reçois
des cadeaux de la vie j'ai vu comment
c'est important pour moi d'être commanda
ici ça fait j'ai 38 ans jce mais
beaucoup et là pour faire un jeu de mots
poche mais comme mon personnage de fans
du ch
je récolte est effectivement je vous
donne l indice les légumes son rang
iphone os le défi était quand même de
taille non de chausser ses souliers là
mais je ne savais pas moi j'ai juste un
petit peu trop vieux qu'un camp
passe-partout a passé à l'époque puis je
sais avec moi je connaissais pas mais je
connaissais passe partout mais je
connais c'est l'oeuvre mais je
connaissais pas je regardais pas sorti
alors quand on m'a appelé pour faire
l'audition je fais ok ma blonde a
maintenant que c'est aujourd'hui un bain
jeu m'avait auditionné pour passeport
tout à fait vrai depuis des cas pas idée
de quoi rire et militer à toute
sincérité taleo 10 années pour farmer je
sais moi aussi mais souhaitent que ses
38 ans près de vienne de pont et gros
légumes le fera un retour en arrière
vous êtes né en haïti cette année au
québec à l'âge de 6 ans je vois que vous
êtes un peu un bourreau de travail parce
que mon petit athlètes
vous avez un groupe a cappella vous
étiez mannequin vous avez fait jour ou
nuit en armes ils donnent vraiment
quelqu'un qui aimait faire plusieurs
choses et vous êtes vraiment curieux le
sait dans votre âme d'artiste mais moi
je la blonde cage
j'aime le voyage et jaja plus beaucoup
beaucoup voyagé puis mais j'aime les
bûches et moi dans la vie comprends-tu
parce que le buffet était si vaste pu
essayer de manger des petites choses
- c'est un peu ça que je suis dans le
fait que je suis pas un spécialiste de
quelque chose mais je suis pas perdre en
plaine
daf puis dans le sport ça a été ça je me
suis pop jupe au fait si je jouais de 17
ans au saccage jouet neuf en valais bas
j'ai joué sept ans au football
jetez pas un spécialiste dernier mais je
me débrouille est quand même assez bien
dans tous puis mon métier c'est ça aussi
puis je pense que ça m'a servi au niveau
de la discipline
- je crois pas aux talents le talent
pour moi n'existe pour moi et l'autre
jour grâce aux deux clichés de la
mutualité mme à 91 d'une crise de rage
au volant
ça vous a vraiment heurter pis pour vous
en sortir nous a plongés dans le karaté
comment canaliser votre énergie je te
balance dans le karaté parce que c'est
l'impression est une balance entre le
métier puis la santé mentale et la santé
physique des écoutes
oui tout à fait b c'est moi le mot le
mot [ __ ] jean tant soit peu juste
content j'ai appris le karaté pour gérer
mon énergie je te jure ce que j'avais
par ces deux mois
c'est quand on dit en bon québécois
revirer de soul
j'avais pas que mes yeux façade même que
je devienne fou puis que à cause d'une
attaque raciste à cause d'une attaque
raciste parce que ce tag heuer est payé
pour toulouse
l'atavisme times si toi qui es tu là
en fouillant dans nos archers je pense
qu un dénominateur commun dans tous vos
rôles c'est votre regard et la flamme
qui est dans vos yeux lorsque vous jouez
où trouvez vous votre plaisir non mais
je te le répète j'ai jamais pensé
honnêtement j'ai puis je joue et je
bloque l'épaule mais j'ai jamais pensé
que j'allais
j'ai jamais pensé que j'aurais la
possibilité de faire ce mythe il aussi
dit
j'ai la flemme parce que j'aime ce
métier j'aime si j'aime ce que je fais
j'ai eu des parents extraordinaire j'ai
un frère une soeur extraction derrière
moi j'ai une femme j'ai dix enfants mais
j'aime ce que je fais puis je veux je
veux allumer les autres a émis ce qu'ils
font cité mais ça fait 38 ans que je
fais ce métier leurs pis que je suis
heureux d'être encore l'eau je suis
heureux qu'on pense à moi je suis rue
peel pensé à moi pour donner une
entrevue
mais j'aime mon métier j'aime ça oui
demi endormi
j'ai un regret j'aurais mes soeurs par
un 30 minutes avait cru tenir leur mail
merci beaucoup de plaisir et pour moi
merci